[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here so you're
overweight and you want to start leading
a healthy lifestyle but you have never
done any exercises before so this
workout is going to get you moving on a
daily basis that's my goal to you
today's workout will be cardio based no
equipment needed only your own body
weight so it's low-impact it's gentle on
your knees but at the same time you will
be working on your muscles that you
don't even know existed okay so only 20
minutes long stop when you need to take
it at your own pace and join me back in
the workout when you're ready everybody
needs a starting point so let's do this
together so I'm gonna take you through a
series of really easy workout to begin
with and I want you to just listen to
your breath and listen to your body and
really engage with all your muscles okay
each workout will be for 40 seconds long
and you will get a 20 seconds break in
between all right so let's start with
marching on the spot okay so just gentle
march on the spot swing your arms relax
your shoulders and just feel your legs
working good March on the spot and get
your call
tighten the at muscles okay it's all
about being conscious about your muscles
so you should feel likes working you
should feel about working at the same
time loosen up your shoulders and just
allow your hands to swing by a side very
nice if you want to push yourself
slightly you can always bring your knees
slightly higher okay
high match and take it down and just
March good 20 seconds of rest okay
the second workout will be a snap Jack
so Stan showed us legs together okay I
want you to just bring your hands up
step side up and step all right
so low impact no jumping at all
got that let's do it together let's go
step and step so reach and step really
stretch your arms all the way up reach
and stay
nice which out toes pointer and step
good and one thing that I always focus
on is your breathing so breathe in and
breathe out okay
pace your breathing good step to the
side good and just listen to your breath
connect with your body breathe in and
out
stretch up okay tie two fingers together
stretch tap to the side you got one more
to go and shake it out just relax
take a deep breath twenty seconds rest
and the next workout will be lake curls
and this workout will really work on
your quads and also your hamstrings okay
so bring your arms up together I want
you to open your chest and just curl one
leg at a time
okay so curl it curl up good curl and
open up your chest you should also feel
your chest working and squeezing your
back muscles good step and another tip
is to always keep your knees bent
okay good step bring your heels to your
butt okay so you should really feel your
hamstrings working if you have tight
hamstrings this is a really good workout
good step find your coordination
very nice last few more keep your arms
up keep your shoulders up and just relax
roll your shoulders shake it out right
the next workout is a ridge and twist
okay so stand slightly wider I wanted to
reach and twist to the opposite side
okay as though you're reaching for
something far away so just reach and
twist point reach and twist okay good
let's go so this workout will also work
on your side apps okay
reach and twist very nice
so really work and fill your side apps
okay twist really twist your hips okay
put that intensity in twist your hips
you shoot through your heart rate going
up slightly reach and twist look the
opposite side if you want to you can
speed up your movement slightly okay
listen to your body take it at your own
pace and twist twist your hips twist
your legs twist your obliques good again
March it out and bring your heart rate
down the next exercise is a squat really
basic from one of the best workouts you
can do for your legs so stand
sugar with a pot toes pointed forward
imagine there's a chair behind you
and I want you to sit with your butt
first okay so just really small movement
you don't have to go too low find a pace
that's comfortable for you okay find a
range that you're comfortable with good
so push your butt back alright sit and
as you come up squeeze those glutes and
engage your glutes squeeze for one
second back down up squeeze good back
down up and squeeze okay so again always
keep your knees slightly bent don't lock
your knees good gentle movements squeeze
down and up give me a few more squeeze
and last one and squeeze very good
alright next
it's a lunge step back okay so I want
you to stand facing forward start with
your left leg going back first alright
so take a step back bend your knees
slightly up and bring it back and the
opposite side okay got that
find your balance let's go step down up
in step down up in good if you want to
challenge yourself then go lower
alright take a wide step back down up
and in very good
okay find your range work on opening up
your hip flexors
and this is also a really good lunch
workout to work on your legs good all
right take it at your own pace find your
balance
tighten your core to find your balance
okay all the exercises it's all about
engaging your core muscles all right
really suck the belly in and feel your
abs working as well rest it out very
nice
next is a standing crunch okay so we
want to work on your core in your
midsection again hence just by your ears
okay all you have to do is twist and try
to bring your elbow to your knee okay
opposite side and try if you can't it's
okay
just reach and twist okay the whole
point is for you to feel that twisting
motion good keep going nice very good
hey stop breathing twist and touch
please and touch okay try to bring your
leg slightly higher up every time you
twist push it a little bit very nice
step twist step and good keep going
bring those legs up and keep your
shoulders and your elbows open last one
more and rest it out you got two more
workouts okay only two more workouts and
you would get a one-minute break let's
work on our upper body right now cross
punch okay
so just stand sugar with a pot slightly
wider bring your hands together by your
face and I want you to just cross and
punch the opposite side very good okay
so punch-drunk pull it back punch and
pull it back good right so always punch
right in the center okay don't punch all
the way there just right in the center
and punch pull it back every time you
punch and pull it back that's when you
work more on your arms okay we like to
show the slightly punch and call your
face good feel your upper body working
good for your arms working and your
shoulders as well good keep going
give me strong punches if you want you
even spit it up slightly and twist and
punch like you mean it
good there you go and just rest it out
one last workout is a low-impact Burpee
ok so we want to get down onto the floor
and get that Cup
alright so let's start by getting down
on the floor down take a left
step back right step back step in in and
just stand alright let's try it together
down left right step in in set up good
touch left back right back in in up nice
let's go again keep going again take it
at your own pace if you want to speed up
you can alright in in and up squeeze
your butt and your legs on the way up
very good keep going because few more so
this is a low-impact burpees going up
your heart rate and rest it up well done
so now take a one-minute break and we
want to repeat all the exercises again
you know the workouts get yourself
hydrated and on the second round really
give me your best effort push it more
bring your heart rate even higher up
okay kiba's have hydrated
[Music]
right wipe your sweat give me your best
energy we have 10 seconds more and it is
round number two you all right
so again engage your core throughout all
the exercises first workout gentle much
on the spot so let's go March on the
spot if you want to like I say bring
your knees up give me a high March
through your arms bring your knees up
work on your legs your bum muscles and
just relax your upper body okay you
should feel your shoulders working
slightly as well so high March as high
as you can get and bring up the speed
slightly more I am sweaty and so you
should be sweating as well keep going
March high March few more last five
seconds get up up and rest it out 20
seconds rest next it's going to be snap
jacks okay so this is the move got it
again if you want to bring up the speed
slightly right five more seconds break
let's get straight into stand jacks
let's go step reach and tap so find your
rhythm it's all about finding your
rhythm and finding your coordination and
keep that movement going okay
don't stop now keep that movement going
it's only 40 seconds let's go tap and
tap very nice
20 seconds you're halfway there breathe
in breathe out
good within breathe out step and step
bend your knees slightly reach up
stretch your upper body good keep going
last few more and rest it out oh my god
Lake curls okay let's go back down and
work on our legs and resolve glutes
again arms up all the time try not to
drop your arms thumbs up you will work
on your shoulders even more right got it
keep your arms up and we want to curl
your legs back okay open and close good
we're going to chest and your back at
the same time okay so it's not just like
oh whatever it's really engaging all
your muscles squeezing your back muscles
squeezing your chest muscles and also
your glutes and hamstrings okay good so
open and close keep your knees bent
don't lock and don't stand too tall okay
check a posture and get your core and
open up your chest nice keep going
few more don't drop your arms now keep
your shoulders up keep your shoulders up
very nice and just shake it out a little
bit
shake it out next stand wider we want to
go for a rich and twist okay
reach and twist again with this movement
it's all about moving your obliques all
right let's go three seconds and go
reach and twist quick pull it back pull
it back arms by your waist pull it back
good grab something and pull it back
nice tap your toe slightly so it's like
a little dance movement reach and twist
keep going
you're halfway there
very good so the goal is to do all these
exercises every day because I wanted to
start moving okay you don't need any
fancy equipment no fancy gym but just do
it from the comfort of your own home
good check it out rest it out squats
okay whatever you do you have to master
how to do a proper squat so again
Sten shutter width apart toes pointed
forward not too wide not too narrow okay
shutter with a part in line with your
body imagine there's a chair behind you
and you want to sit with your butt first
so but push up and sit okay you don't
have to go too low all right if you want
to challenge yourself then of course go
deeper
squat deeper but beginner just small
gentle movement to really engage the
glutes and the legs squeeze your buttock
right at the top good squeeze and
squeeze good very good okay it's not
about going fast or you know going too
fast it's about getting the right form
to begin with let's get squat deeper if
you want to push back squat even deeper
push back and remember always push up
with the Hughes okay last one and just
rest it out 20 seconds rest I am
sweating my sweat is dripping and I hope
you're sweating too next workout is
going to be a step back to lunch okay
so Stan showed up with a pot again step
back lunge bend slightly step in and
change side okay ready let's go together
step back lunge in and step back okay
engage your core the whole goal is to
engage your core to find your balance
again if you want to challenge yourself
you can go deeper so lunch lower and
push up with the front leg lunch down
push up with a front leg step back lunge
push up with the front leg very good
challenge yourself push higher up step
and up nice you're doing such a good job
keep going last few more good you should
feel glutes working
one more give me one more on the other
side okay down and shake it out shake it
out now let's work on standing crunches
so we want to work on your midsection um
just where is gentle the goal is to
bring your elbow to your knee knee okay
and you should feel your abs your side
ABS crunching together let's go crunch
step crunch okay so really suck the
belly in to find your balance
don't lose balance okay so suck it in
stand tall open your chest and crunch
the opposite side very good keep going
crunch and look straight ahead good
twist feel your obliques working the
side of the apps and at the same time
feel Knicks working every time you bring
your legs up that's when you will work
on your thigh muscles keep going crunch
higher up come on let's speed it up
slightly one last one and rest it out
upper body punches okay I wanted to
punch like you mean it
and finally them don't stop keep
punching alright so I'm up just like a
fighter and I want it to twist your body
left your right good
got that let's go you're a fighter
good I know you're a fighter that's a
fighter in you I want you to sweat and
fear sweat dripping and I don't want you
to stop right now because you're going
to finish the entire workout with me
punch and pull it back good punch like
you mean it
twist feel a big working and keep going
bend your knees slightly
alright keep going whoo breathe out whoo
all right let's do it few more kukuku
five more seconds keep going
no no don't stop now your arms your
shoulders working last few more give it
all and rest it out last workout
low-impact burpees so get down onto the
floor step up and stand
okay wipe your sweat slightly huh drench
in sweat
one less workout and you know what you
deserve a really good break and a pad
right let's go
umm don't step back step forward and
straight up okay
focus on your posture when you step up
look straight and give me a nice tall
standing position good back in stand
tall very nice in okay find your rhythms
back and in and push your butt and your
body upright so push use the momentum to
come back up last workout guys
you got this five more seconds and give
me one more okay give me one more and
just shake it off well done so that was
a twenty minute
low-impact workout which you can start
to do on a daily basis okay
it is low-impact its gentle on your
knees but the goal is to really get your
heart rate working your heart rate
pumping all right so I want to encourage
you to do this workout every single day
when you feel like you can push yourself
more that increase the work up to three
sets or even four sets to challenge
yourself even more you can add and lift
some weights let me know what is your
goal for this year what is a fitness
goal in the comments below I want you to
keep me posted
on the regular basis because we want to
motivate each other and we want to keep
each other updated all right be sure to
like this video share this video with
your friends and get them to start
getting active workout together push
each other motivate each other and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more workout videos healthy recipes
and also fitness tips turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I share a new video
all the best you got this